quelle est la pensée David Raskin Je
voulais juste une seconde chance pensez-vous que nous
pouvons aller en prison hamburgers quel est ce
projet Almanach emplacement temporel c'est
une machine à voyager dans le temps prenons cette chose
pour un tour développez mes 32 gagnants à la
loterie nous allons  être si riche que je vais
embaucher Kim Kardashian avoir mon bébé oh hé
bienvenue chez Maserati J'allais soit en
acheter un ou 17 Toyota Corollas
J'aime voyager dans le temps
regarde ça c'est moi qui dors ce que je
ne voulais pas blesser qui que ce soit
a ajouté des effets d'entraînement fous des émeutes
désastreuses rien de tout cela ne s'est produit avant que
vous ne vous souciez pas que tous vos amis
puissent être blessés et qu'il empêche cette machine
d'être construite Je suis retourné seul
combien de fois l'avez-vous fait
vous